hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by metro and
i'm
really excited about this particular
video because it means
i get to eat my favorite meal of the day
breakfast
and i get to do it seven times so yeah
it's gonna be a good day but i think i
like breakfast because
i like sweet things and i feel like
breakfast is like a socially accepted
time to eat a lot of sweet things
as a meal even though side note we are
all adults folks so
we can have maple syrup any time of day
if we want to
am i right before we get into it i want
to talk about my sponsor metro
and their new my health my choices
program now i know that it's
new year new you season but instead of
the standard juice cleanses
and detoxes that we see advertised a lot
this time of year
i really want to encourage you to focus
on tools
that will help to promote moderate
sustainable lifestyle changes
it starts in the grocery store by making
more nutrient-dense choices
and metro's new my health my choices
program makes it easier than ever to
find what your family needs
so the my health my choices program is a
simple shopping guide
that helps consumers make the right
choices for them
based on their lifestyle dietary
restrictions
or nutritional goals so metro has
actually worked with credible experts to
curate over 40 different dietary
attributes
across thousands of products and made it
really easy to find and shop for them
in store on their app and online i
really think that for a lot of people
grocery shopping with all the competing
claims and trends
can be really overwhelming i mean we
can't all have a dietitian
shopping with us and guiding our
purchasing decisions in store or online
but this is
literally the next best thing in my
opinion so
i'm really excited to see this program
take off so
next time you grocery shop choose metro
to ensure your shop is seamless
and meets your nutritional needs all
right let's talk
breakfast so i was inspired to make this
particular video by linda suns
taste testing people's protein pancake
recipes
i thought that was a really fun video to
watch and i thought i would take all of
your suggestions
and try out your favorite influencers go
to
breakfast recipes you know the ones that
they make like again
and again and again and somehow
seem to never get sick of so i'm gonna
do a
full week seven days of their go-to
breakfast and i'm gonna eat them all
in one go and i'm gonna let you know how
i feel about them
ranking them on nutrition flavor
and presentation this is basically my
way of living out my own
lifelong dream of being a judge on a
food network
cooking show so yeah food number if
you're watching this
you know where to find me all right
lovelies let's brunch
day one first breakfast we're gonna do
emma chamberlain's avocado toast now
it's time to start making breakfast
we're gonna be making avocado toast
because it's the only thing i know how
to cook
which is unfortunate and this is one
that you guys recommended a lot
and i can see why because i really
really love emma
okay so i'm gonna basically just like
follow along with her
making this and it starts of course
with the avocado and i've got so many
here because i'm not quite sure which
one's going to be
perfect this is
check at the beauty all right
so that looks good i gotta get a bowl
here so
we don't need the pit she is
smashing it up classic avocado toast
move
so lots of smashing nothing's been added
quite yet
i feel like that's good okay salt
salty salt lemon juice
and then she's got garlic powder and
onion powder not sure how i feel about
that
i don't love garlic powder and lemon
powder it just
always feels a little matte
oh chili flakes mmm do i have chili
flakes
missed that all right she
took a sip of her coffee so
gotta work that in of course make it
very authentic
crusty sourdough
now she said she toasted it in the oven
i'm gonna have time for that but i'm
gonna do it authentic
keeping it real you know when you're a
mom when you literally
just eat the crumbs because it means
less of a mess to clean up
i resorted to just putting it on broil
because
i don't want to wait any longer but i
also know that that is dangerous
because one second too long on broil
y'all know what happens
okay so i think this is what we're going
with because i don't want it to get
burnt and this is feeling nice and
crusty on the outside but still pillowy
on the inside and that is how i like it
so let's see what else she's doing now
this makes sense
this is a large piece
of bread so i do have seven breakfast to
get through so
wish me luck
little drizzy dress
now we're having fun everything but the
bagel seasoning
yes ma'am and then the hot sauce just a
touch
just a touch this is breakfast so
i'm gonna give this a solid eight out of
ten
on the presentation nutrition loving it
we've got lots of healthy fats
some it from the oil and the avocado
we've got some
nice crusty sourdough bread in here for
our carbs
we could boost up the protein if we
wanted to if you want to throw an egg on
there i know sometimes that she does
or of course you could also do what i do
i've got a recipe
where i puree in some white beans and
that's a really great hack too
all the time i love that but anyways
let's give this a taste
trying to get all the things on
this one's gonna be a hot contender next
all right
day two is greg ducette's anabolic
french toast
and today we're making anabolic french
toast
this one starts with egg whites which
i've just put into
a bowl here i'm following along with
with greg as he does it
he uses some non-calorie sweetener
vanilla he's got very specific
measurements that i'm definitely not
measuring but
a quarter of a teaspoon is what his
recipe says two shakes cinnamon
and then the bread all right so we've
just got
good old-fashioned white bread he also
sometimes
he says he uses like a protein bread or
white bread
but i got white bread who doesn't love
some good old
sandwich bread so i'm gonna he soaks
them he like
i mean really gets them going saturates
oh it's like falling apart
maybe it's just the protein bread that
he soaks
we might have to try this a few times he
calls it regular ass bread which is what
i'm using
but this is completely fallen apart as
you can see
so that one didn't work let's
dip dip that's quick quick quick
into the pan we'll do two
maybe more depending on how these turn
out dip dip dip
let's do one more soak her up soak up
the it's very good idea i mean there's
lots of protein here
mistakes mistakes have been made
oh he's like soaking her in there
i want to make sure greg is proud of me
all right these are cooking they look
pretty good
they look really good
nice noise nice this mama
yeah lucky lucky
i'm excited start plating these bad boys
nice this one's this one's the prettiest
so i'm gonna make sure greg's hero shot
looks
she looks good okay guys i totally
deserve brownie points for
um authenticity here uh because i went
out and bought
walden farms no calorie pancake syrup
which is basically what all of these
guys
use so i figured we had to make it
super legit it doesn't run the same way
that a good
maple does but we're going to work with
it
so all right
now the moment of truth i'm going to
give this
a 6 out of 10 for presentation i mean
i'm excited about any kind of french
toast to be quite honest any kind of
carb
so i'm i am genuinely excited and i was
surprised
i think that the cinnamon does help give
it the browning look which is what i was
worried that we've been missing out on
without having like lots of butter and
egg yolks in the mix so
that's good nutrition not bad i mean
white bread
we could add some whole grains in there
and do like a nice crusty whole grain
bread or the sourdough bread
would be a really great choice but i get
why greg goes for
the the basic white bread it's a great
source of carbs and if that's what
you're needing after like a workout for
recovery
great and then of course lots of protein
in here as well
now if i was going to make this i'd
throw some nut butter on top just to add
some
some some healthy fats but again i get
why greg doesn't
it's not on his plan he's looking to you
know get as much protein as possible
and uh and balance it out with those
carbs so totally totally get it for his
goals
and then taste gotta taste it so
i'm not sure that this kind of bread
is made for french toast tastes like
soggy
wet bread and i mean i got browning but
it's just
basic sandwich bread is not meant for
french toast sorry
just not just not okay let's put that
aside because
i'm still hungry and there are more
breakfast recipes to make
okay next we're gonna do stephanie
buttermore's
cake pop oatmeal this is gonna come to
no surprise to you that i
still have cake pop protein oatmeal
every day which i've seen her make
a million times and you guys probably
have too so i'm excited to try this
and i went all out and i went and i
found it
the cake pop protein powder because i
want to make sure that this was
super authentic for our girl stephanie
so i've cooked the oats which is kind of
like how i seen her do it
and then we're going to add in the
protein powder a full scoop
and she always is like i can just hear
her in my head she's like
your girl likes it thick thick so i'm
trying to make it thick even though
that's so not my preference so i might
need to add
like a little bit of almond milk just to
loosen that up because it is looking
just a touch i would other like i like
my oats like
soup so like really really loose so i
get that's like really weird
leave me a comment below how you like
your oats and then of course
she just like loads it up with all the
goodies so raspberries
smells like a putty cause that's when
you'd have a cake pop
and i even also went out on my way to
get the
uh what's called protein cereal that she
uses for the little crunch back duck
that's what she wrote my folks let's see
okay so i would say
appearance wise i'm gonna give this a
solid six or seven out of ten i like the
color i like the crunch i like the
different things going on
nutrition on point we've got lots of
complex fiber rich carbs in the oats and
the cereal and the fruit
protein and the protein powder we could
add a little bit of like nut batter on
top if we wanted to
up the fats but i would say for a
post-workout meal this
is basically perfection so let's try to
get all the goodies
in one big bite
that's so good i see why she's obsessed
it is a little chalky for my taste like
kind of starts to coat my mouth so i
don't know that i could eat like a whole
massive bowl but it's tasty all right
day four
we're gonna do linda sun's protein
pancake linda sun she's not that special
not even a fitness influencer but she is
addicted to pancakes and if you guys
have not tried to recipe out i don't
know what you guys are doing but you
should probably go try them out
and i'm excited about this because i
like linda sun and i
feel like she would probably have some
good protein pancakes she eats them
every single day
so let's see how these how these are all
right first thing
we've got a little cozy boylsey so
banana
i also love adding sweetness natural
sweetness with a banana into
like all my recipes i use a lot of
bananas
oats got an
eggy protein powder
baking powder it's like a splash
of almond milk a little sprinkle
cinnamon let's get her going
let's see smells good
nice pancake like texture
all right we'll do tiny little babes
gotta love the look of pancakes when
they're frying up like that
oh oh very important very important here
folks
she's got chocolate chips even if these
don't turn out well
they're gonna be all right if there's
some chocolate inside please flipping
gods
give me some power yeah not bad
they're coming out nice oh i just nicked
that one
yeah oh you know when you get to the
edge one and you're like how am i going
to
maple syrup that's what we need
okay i'm gonna say that's done now she'd
go in there
with like a serious glob of some
crunchy natural hey b
oh yeah can we give them like sexy music
[Music]
i didn't mean to be sensual and
suggestive on that finger lick
all right bananas she likes lots of
fruit i know
i know you guys will be like more fruit
more berries well
folks berries are out of season and they
are getting really expensive
so your girl is just going to try to
keep things on budget for just a hot
minute
but a little maple syrup never hurt
anyone we're canadian
gotta support the canadians
presentation i mean gorge
who doesn't love pancakes with peanut
butter and maple syrup and fruit on top
um so i'm gonna give that like a easy
eight out of ten not gourmet of course
but she looks good
nutrition also great we've got whole
grains in there
fruit we've got protein from the protein
powder we've got fats from the nut
butter
can't go wrong with this taste
that is delicious with the chocolate mmm
from the crunchy peanut butter
it's been a while since i've had crunchy
peanut butter well that is a good
solid nine or ten i mean really can't
critique that
all right on to the next one okay recipe
number five and this time we're doing
chloe ting's breakfast pancakes for
protein pancakes
your girl here is craving for those
japanese
fluffy pancakes so this is gonna be
different a little head-to-head action
but they look so different that i
figured we would do both of them
and i think i got a little overzealous
on the addition of the butter so i'm
just gonna
take a little of that out first things
first
egg yolks and egg whites separated in
two bowls all right let's do it
oh let's do the egg whites here very
important of course that we don't
mix egg whites and
egg yolk like the egg yolk doesn't end
up into the egg white if we're trying to
beat it nice and fluffy like a meringue
so separate that out one now when i'm
doing like a huge batch of separating
egg whites and egg yolks i would always
make sure to do them like one at a time
into a ramekin because if
one breaks and you get one piece of yolk
in your egg whites
the whole the whole batch is gone so
that's going in
a little beet and she has
beaten in almond flour
and coconut flour and her recipe is all
in gram so
your girl had to get the the kitchen
scale out this morning which was
not something i like to do on a busy
morning see this is so thick so hers was
like super thick like that too
and she was like you need to add a
little bit of almond milk so she did
like three tablespoons of almond milk
a little bit of vanilla
why
this one is a labor of love so it better
be really really really damn good
[Music]
floofy floofy look at that
now you fold the meringue
into the egg yolks you just
that's what you do you just fold it in
okay i don't know how to fold broken
cheese like that and i don't know how to
be any clearer
you take that thing that's in your hand
uh-huh and you if you say fold in
one more time fold it in
you fold it in okay so i'm not
i'm not winning any emmys anytime soon
but i can i can appreciate
a good canadian comedy all right so that
looks weird but i'm hoping the rest of
it
really helps to floof it up a little bit
meanwhile let's get our pan hot her egg
yolk consistency was like a lot smoother
despite the fact that i even got
the whisk out for it well these are
gonna be what it's gonna be and chloe if
i don't do your beautiful pancakes
justice
my apologies but i'm making seven damn
recipes today
and i am hungry and i'm tired
i think it'll be okay though i think it
might just be my coconut flowers a
little bit more
oh i didn't whisk like she did all right
let's make
a chloe pancake
zoom zoom zoom we're going to the moon
maybe i didn't whip my egg weights quite
enough
fair no
got close to the edge so yeah they're
light they're supposed to be light i
haven't messed this up
quite yet she just made bigger ones than
me and that is
okay we don't need to you know size does
not matter
i'm just ready to go in now so we plate
honey
i'm gonna do it the way you would intend
chloe suggests
serving this with a little bit butter a
nice pat of butter on top
and some berries and of course
maple syrup so that's how we roll oh
nothing like
that look when the butter kind of like
falls off your pancakes
okay so what are my thoughts
so appearance they look pretty good i
mean
i gotta say the nut butter on linda's
totally
it just gave me some really good feels
let's just say that
um but i think these look great they
kind of look like cornbread
patties to me which are always fun
nutrition wise they're pretty great
we've got the egg whites and the eggs
and then we've got a combination of
coconut flour and almond flour which are
packed with
fiber and protein and healthy fats and
stuff like that so that's really great
and then of course
a little maple syrup never hurt anyone
um definitely brings little carbs and we
got the fruit so
let's give one of these fluffies a taste
oh
they are fluffy hi baby
pretty good flavor is great fluffy
it could be more fluffy coconut flour is
a challenging one but i like the flavor
that adds to this
but it does require a lot more eggs
because it is so dry
so yeah i would be interested to try
this with just like
regular whole wheat flour or just all
almond flour
just to see how that would change things
but pretty solid cool recipe did take a
long time to make though
gotta say that and dirtied a lot of
bowls don't always love doing that but
anyways let's move on
all right now here is a recipe i'm not
sure if i'm excited about
but i am kind of thrilled at how easy it
is
and that is joanna's avocado wrap
finally the holy grail the avocado
tortilla the love i have for this
strange dish is immeasurable
and let's get into it it's pretty
self-explanatory but
of course i do want to make sure that
i'm watching her tutorial to make sure i
do it
authentically she cuts her avocado
in a way that i am a little bit more
concerned about
so avocado she's having it with some
milk
which is a lovely combination um i'm
just going to do straight up because you
know
i'm trying to be fair trying to make
sure i have an appetite for my last
recipe as well
for a fair judging but she just kind of
smashes this bad boy in
and really when you think about it it's
basically just avocado
toast on a slightly different vehicle am
i right
i'm not sure if she adds salt but i
honestly think that avocado without salt
is
really offensive so don't offend me
throw a little salt on there
and then we roll we do a little
rolling with the homie
a little a little clueless reference
just like that i guess that's it folks
all right so uh my thoughts
appearance i don't know what to say i
mean
it's a wrap with some green stuff inside
so i'm gonna give it like a three
and that's being generous i guess we
could throw some vegetables in there to
make a little more
appetizing but i guess i get that it's
supposed to be convenient
easy straight to the point got it
nutrition
not bad but we're missing the protein i
mean literally just um we've got some
whole grain tortilla which adds a little
bit of fiber plus there's lots of fiber
and avocado as well
and those healthy fats so that's great
this would be a good snack
maybe not so much breakfast for me at
least i would be
pretty hangry but let's have a tasty
i'm glad i added salt wouldn't have been
edible
otherwise it's okay but i feel like if
i'm gonna eat a lot of avocado
she needs a good bread partner yeah
maybe this is like
like a four all right what's next okay
finally day seven breakfast seven i am
excited to get through this last one
because i've been cooking breakfast all
day but this is gonna be
misfit and nerdy's breakfast frosty
smoothie
this is a chocolate smoothie but it's
mostly vegetables
i love a good frosty from wendy's i
don't know if you guys do but that is
that sounds like a good idea to me so
let's get this
party started okay so into the blender
we've got frozen sweet potato that
is already cooked and then frozen which
she specifies
in the recipe we've also got some frozen
cauliflower that's going in
frozen zucchini that's going in
we have some ginger not sure what ginger
is doing in frosty but i'll take it
some collagen powder so
i guess to add some extra protein she
said either like a vegan coconut yogurt
or kefir yogurt
so that's what this is running out of
spoons here folks so we are scraping the
barrel
bottom of the barrel of my cutlery
drawer and then i suppose
oh we got avocado too yup she said
look either fresh or frozen avocado love
how convenient this frozen avocado is
now
so that goes in i think she's like half
a pot of color which would be about that
the cacao which i assume is what's going
to make it like a chocolate frosty
and then of course it has to be thick
because like a frosty is like ice cream
thick
so just a little bit to stir and then we
can add more is what she suggests so
let's do it
all right i actually think this is a
good consistency that's
chocolaty look at this mama
okay so oh yeah um
well let's talk about this in order so
first of all presentation
looks like a thick chocolate smoothie
meats mousse
so that's a good thing second thing
nutrition pretty great we've got
lots of protein in here from the
collagen we've got tons of fruits and
vegetables some healthy fats in the
avocado
so let's give a full taste
nope don't like it
don't like it
[Music]
too chocolatey for me even though i did
follow exactly what she suggested
to cocoae and not enough sweetness to
balance it out in my opinion
if you really love like hard fast bitter
dark chocolate like a good 80 90 percent
you might like this
also i find like the ginger doesn't
belong in a frosty
texture is great but i would throw like
a banana in here or some dates
or some maple syrup just to balance
things out a little bit and maybe
leave the ginger for like tea or
something
so i'm going to give this like i don't
want to offend but like a two
i wouldn't drink it okay folks seven
influencers seven breakfasts which
would be the one that i actually want to
eat right now and finish up
it's hard to choose just one especially
when it's like do i want sweet do i want
savory
but i think my personal go-to
would be the avocado toast even though
it's getting brown
and it's like getting a little soggy i'd
go for this one
what kind of stuff everything bagel
spice wins
every single time but also honorable
mention for the pancakes
gonna have another little bite of that
and maybe this maybe i'll do this too
guess you can tell i'm hungry
all right folks so i think what we
learned today is that there are a lot of
really great
breakfast recipes on youtube really easy
breakfast recipes that you could
incorporate into your week as well
i think we also learned that i'm not so
good at following
recipe instructions and i'm really
impatient as well so
great some fun facts about abby um but
of course
thank you again to metro for sponsoring
this video if you liked it if you want
to see more fun vlog videos like this
leave me a comment below
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen
bye